don't invest in someone based on how
much you like them you invest in them
based on how much they invest in you
that time that value you should put in
should be expensive
it should come at a high cost
and the cost is i'm willing to give you
the world
as long as you meet me there
pay very close attention to whether this
person is bringing you the same amount
of value
the person who's looking to understand
the good and the bad in you
and who elevates the good
and soothes the bad
that's
something very beautiful to look out for
standing out has become more important
than ever for a lot of people they're
not experiencing what they see as an
endless ocean of choice what they're
experiencing is an endless ocean of
disappointment of constantly talking to
people with it not going anywhere or you
know meeting someone it seems to be
going well for a few dates and all of a
sudden they disappear it's not enough to
think they're great the relationship
itself has to provide you with value
because if you're with someone who's
massively impressive
but the relationship itself
does not bring you value does not bring
you joy then you are in a world of
suffering and pain no matter how
wonderful the person you're with is and
your reality
isn't determined by how impressive they
are but how beautiful the ecosystem of
the relationship is that's what's going
to determine your emotional reality and
your emotional reality is going to
determine your happiness great
relationships are an accumulation of
little efforts
over time the big ground things are a
nice bonus but you don't have to do them
because your partner or your friend or
your
lover or whatever is aware of what a
lovely
kind considerate interesting person you
are the rest of the time
it's the same as going to the gym you
know it's like how you think we're going
to get a great body because one day we
do a really hard gym session
no it's just every day do the reps do
the reps in your relationship what's
important in a relationship is someone
who is really competent
in a relationship
so i think that there's a learning that
we get from relationships but in order
to do that you actually have to be in a
space of being willing to put eyes on
yourself yeah and in a constant student
mindset which most of us are not you
know we do go into relationships a lot
of us thinking we know it all we learnt
it all from our last relationship it's a
cliche but they're just
there's always another level there are
so many levels to life and it fascinates
me great relationships should help heal
past wounds in some way because it's two
people who make each other feel safe
feel loved but what we can't do
is blame someone for not being able to
handle our weapons one of the biggest
problems is people
falling for people really quickly
falling in love too fast
anyone anyone can go on a date and
dazzle for five minutes
and then if you don't get any more of
that person then it just they just feel
dazzling
and when someone's only giving you five
percent of their energy
it's really easy for them to remain
mysterious and exciting
what's exciting about the beginning of a
relationship is that we don't feel like
we've fully figured each other out well
i want to see how you are in week four
yeah or i want to see how you are in
month three yeah or and until you've
been there you really don't know how
great of a partner somebody is gonna be
that we learn a lot in the moments where
you have your
first fight
or you
reveal something about yourself
and you see how they react
to it you can't know what this person is
like in year three of a relationship you
don't know what that person is like in
those stages so
so thinking that you have all the
answers because you've been on
even 10 or 15 dates with this person and
had a wonderful time
is a fallacy a fantasy
when two people
really know each other
there's that sense that these are two
completely known
quantities
now from one aspect that's really
attractive because it's it creates love
it creates connection it creates a bond
but from another perspective there's
that part of our mind that still wants
to be challenged that still wants to
feel like there's there's something
to do here and
one of the greatest ways to you know i
think it's a time old question how do we
challenge someone in a relationship when
we already know everything about each
other and we already feel like we have
each other it could be reading a new
book so that you have a different
conversation to bring today it could be
learning a new skill it could be
performing well at something proust said
the journey of discovery lies not in
seeking new landscapes but in seeing
with new eyes
so many people expect their partner to
be a mind reader yes
and they're not
and just giving them
a blueprint of how to please you
of how to make you happy we should be
always paying attention to the things
your partner says to you i think one of
the greatest things the greatest values
that keeps a relationship going is
teamwork
and i mean not just the kind of teamwork
of we're on a joint vision together but
the kind of teamwork that says we are a
team in making each other as happy as
possible and if they tell you something
this is going to really please me if you
do it
then you should be doing that thing and
if you're with someone that too many
times in a row you keep saying these
things make me really happy when you do
them and they don't compromise your
values
they're just effort if you're in a
relationship where someone doesn't do
those things
then you have to start questioning is
this a teammate i really don't like the
idea that we have to be
completely happy and
enlightened and have everything figured
out and that's when the right person
comes along i think that's nonsense we
are always working on something we're
always going through some new problems
some new stage in our life that we
weren't ready for
and
we are going to do an awful lot of
healing of who you can be
so i prefer rather than thinking we have
to be happy before we find someone i
prefer the idea that we have to be happy
enough
before we meet someone happy enough is a
much better phrase and it's a much more
attainable
goal when you're happy enough it means
i'm happy enough
i'm not my life's not perfect and i
might not be truly happy all the time
but i'm happy enough
with the way my life is today and with
who i am today
i have never in my life
met someone
who is truly nice i never met someone
who was truly nice
i find that people who say they're nice
are using it as a euphemism for being
spineless
bending on their standards never rocking
the boat compromising to everyone around
them being the lowest common denominator
of any group they're in so as never to
offend or inflame
not only is that unimaginably boring
but it also describes someone who you
don't know who you're dealing with you
don't know what they're really feeling
they're not honest about their feelings
about other people they're not honest
about the things that aggravate them or
annoy them in life they tend to just
keep things on an even keel the entire
time i think we should stop seeing it as
some sort of noble word or some sort of
noble human trait
what happens by the way to nice people i
find they don't stay nice forever they
actually become bitter or resentful
because
they get angry at the world for treating
them badly secondly they get angry at
themselves because they can't believe
that they would allow themselves to be
walked all over they get angry that they
allow people to step on them when they
should be out there going and claiming
what they want i believe that kind
people
deserve the world
kind people should be given
every award kind people should be given
every bit of recognition kind people
make the world a better place
not nice people
i struggle with the concept that
relationships should be easy i don't
have a single relationship that hasn't
involved pain
i believe our life gets better in direct
proportion to the number of difficult
conversations we're willing to have the
choosing of a right partner is one of
the most important decisions that we
will ever make love at first sight is
this great myth that we're supposed to
meet someone know that they're the one
and then we invest in them because
they're the one
and i think that often it works the
other way around you meet someone yes
they have a lot of the qualities that
you really want in a person yes there is
some initial chemistry but then they
become the one by what you invest in
them and by what they invest in you you
create something special because you
build it together the problem is if
you're so fixated on worrying about
whether someone is the right person you
never actually invest enough to get past
the tipping point of feeling like you've
got something incredibly special on your
hands the goal of any relationship
shouldn't be that the other person lives
up to this
this pedestal
that we've put them on the goal should
be a real connection with who that
person really is my challenge to you and
i want to take up this challenge myself
as well because it's not easy when
someone does something that doesn't fit
with your exact version of them again
ask yourself that question do i want a
relationship with
the my idea of them or do i want a
relationship with the them that actually
exists this one is going to create much
more depth slight changes in mindset
essentially change our entire lives
every ounce of our success and the
opportunities we get can be determined
by millimeter shifts in the difference
in our mindset